and welcome to punch-drunk sportswear
winners win today blonde joke is brought
to you by Spotify hey did you know
punch-drunk is now available on Spotify
Spotify is making it easy for you to
stream this podcast and many more like
it on your mobile device desktop app and
smart speaker open the app on the mobile
or desktop click on the Browse channel
and then click on the podcast section
take us with you wherever you go
thanks to Spotify thank you guys guys
you know who we are
you know what we're here I use modify
all the time I do too and I am premium
member actually oh yeah I think you
gotta get it to get the playlist like 9
bucks a month no you get everything ever
you can share music I can like you know
Yusef and I constantly send stuff back
and I can make a playlist on Spotify and
send it to my buddy yeah I did is it a
happy birthday here's [ __ ] or a chick
it's like the wit you can make a mixtape
for a chick I like that it's like boo
this is what I think about you BAM yep I
love a Soufan answer your podcast at the
end of it all of them all being even
ninety 92.7 of all the new ones coming
out today came out this morning oh [ __ ]
hot drop 92.7 the pod just came out this
morning Jon REEP Sarah Tiana
Justin Martindale Jeff Scott plays a lot
of music it's it's a great came out
today speaking of great podcast these
guys they aren't on one but they are
trying a great podcast it's called the
store horsemen
please welcome ah I call it my ponies
the black manager Chris Burns and Josh
Martin from the store horsemen guys
welcome oh hey guys what up yeah you
might remember Josh Martin from
punch-drunk he's the guy that had to
wipe his face with calm yeah ladies and
gentlemen can we give this guy a round
of applause why is his face with
everybody's come from this show yeah was
it like that was not as bad as maybe
putting a hot dog
yeah okay Baghdad being paywall Lord
ever
it'll get paid off today I would rather
I would rather put a hot dog in my bath
that was not calm it was so quick that
it was such a short come on but it was
let's show it what what do we have
yeah we do L know yeah I was there I was
there in a balcony well I loved how you
got this is my favorite part of this you
have plastic gloves on so not to get the
jizz on your hand but you're good on
your face your eyes in your mouth and
actually what is way worse than for the
guy on the front row Gallagher tree yeah
put the towel in the cup of well then
took it out the water splash on again
and he was in the bathroom gloves off
first before he was like I would go
Ronnie special I'd go right for a towel
but he's like what it doesn't show is
how cloudy the water got in so my
favorite and water dip it yeah just
[ __ ] jizz bad yes so there was a guy
in the front row in the bathroom with
washing his hands with me look at the
guys all over here that is so far son of
a [ __ ] I'll say the funniest thing
about this re look at re like it makes
re sink all three of us were a
completely separate parts of the country
I'm in the middle I'm in Chicago Sam's
in LA Ari's in New York and then we're
doing this bet and we realized this has
to happen I had the wherewithal to go
alright here's what I'll be it off on
first and then I'll send it to Ari and
then use it because I didn't want to get
the like a mail in my mail yeah
everybody's semen samples so I beat off
on it first I cut a sleeve off of the
shirt jerked off on it
send it to Ari in New York did you let
it dry before you sent it to Ari I mean
it yeah yeah I didn't like a mailbox
beating off
he beats off sends it to the Comedy
Store for Sam and it's oh no and it goes
attention uh Adam II get do not eat and
then Sam just beat off on it at the
counter like no problems I walked in
like a rabbit yeah those were the good
days glory days but nobody a year ago
unlike Sam I am NOT a Walter here we go
again with this [ __ ] okay let's go down
who owes [ __ ] bets off this guy has
to walk as a [ __ ] down the [ __ ]
[ __ ] lane for an hour and a half and
get his bow shock hour for an hour and
get his ball shocked and involved
already has to do [ __ ] hot dog in the
bud I get cry and [ __ ] raise money
he's planning on he's got to get the USA
chant going and I think he should have
to do that in Australia that would be
great I'm not against that if he
attempts it and it doesn't get going but
he has a good video on punch honks thing
now dude no we're not we're not giving
him a now cuz he'd never give us and uh
I think that's a if for 30 seconds he's
chanting USA on an Australian boss or
whatever and no one gets it going but he
gives the video to us of him fail with
that epic fail and post it on
punch-drunk
I'll take that all right I don't know if
I will but you know that doesn't mean
anything we'll take it to although ah so
yeah so the notion I'm the welter
doesn't make any sense it's just this
[ __ ] Jew propaganda that I've been up
started by started by Ari Shaffir and
the merry clan his work he got all the
newspapers all the media Rachel Maddow's
talked about it it's [ __ ] deep guys
ah March 25th
I am doing my live video I'm shooting my
special live at the Viper Room it is
March 25th at 7:30 and 9:30 if you'd
like to go
please email me at Sam Tripoli live at
gmail so email me I'd love to have you
guys come it's starting to fill up I'm
about halfway through on both shows I
think we're only gonna put a hundred in
so it should be fun I'm debating whether
I should add these [ __ ] certain jokes
that piss people off but it makes me
feel good ah got anything you want to
pro any place you're gonna be and he
shows you on promote um no I'll be at
parlor live next weekend yes so that's a
Tony and then I'm in Kansas City
Missouri but Pauly Shore sometime in
April that's [ __ ] great
that's a date but my me to do an
impression later of both of you guys on
the road together guys it's your buddy
the team the new episode of 92 7 the pod
came out today so listen to it download
it and I'm at the fart dungeon all of
Moon Tober and then I'm at pew cuts open
mic in July of 2020 I'm killing myself
tonight and I'm at the Laker game right
before that with Johnny so if you want
to see me I'll be at the Laker game and
uh let's see I watch the show love have
you seen that yeah what about it they
get married at the end spoiler alert so
I'm at spoilers to come to that come to
that they get married it you just ruined
the entire I only ruined episode 13
that's a no that's fair the relationship
I'm offended it's great Bobby Lee is
great in that by the way he's done he's
a pending thing you're promoting anybody
check out like you said man stole horse
from podcast us about it you know it's a
bunch of dumb [ __ ] talking about Pro
Wrestling in honor of the late great
Roddy Piper who used to hang around the
comedy store with us we do that every
week every week you talked about Roddy
Piper not talk about Roddy Piper we
talked about Pro Wrestling you know I
mean but Piper comes up quite regularly
he was the best and oh he was he was
beyond nice one of the grace things I've
ever done in my life was orchestrating
the rowdy can you find that Roddy Piper
versus the amazing racist it was one of
the [ __ ] coolest things ever because
you didn't know how this crowd was gonna
take it yeah here it is can we watch
that real quick oh that's a this is the
quick version no no no I wanna hear the
part where a date Dana D Armand is
getting her award and here we go okay
yeah pass that pass and it was awesome
until all of a sudden jung-woo from the
shadows the amazing racist very angry
still in the back i spray-painted out
[Music]
Dana had the Armand is the Jackie
Onassis of pornography like she's just
classy
that question they'd like to ask lovely
dignity anybody before you hold on
myspace post in the background hi how
are you fear and I am the amazing racist
just on the one hand over there oh what
a dumbass
how lucid you are saying
[Music]
I do it was going to that
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
this day is the best thing it was on TMZ
the next day yeah that's it cuz it was
the best thing we ever did I did alive
done a lot of stuff Tebow and I'd done a
lot of stuff together but that was by
far the best thing we've ever done
pinnacle of my of what I've done here
you can stop it we don't need to know
how did or how did our Easter look less
Jewish and become more Jewish at the
same time as you guys well as your
career gets bigger you wanna you know
you know who runs everything so you got
to do kowtow to them so you know like
you look more super Jewish that's how it
goes
and that was how to make it in Hollywood
with punches should I look less black as
I get old no you uncle I see now and
that won't be the gate more black that's
true Black Panther is yeah yeah I know I
mean everybody it's right over left but
you're me what kind of favor uh I think
I said on the patreon my favorite joke
Cree Matthews who I love had the best
joke who's like black panther like three
hundred and fifty million dollars in
ticket sales sixty one dollars in
concession ya know a million people made
that exact same joke like sixteen dollar
concession yeah have a friend who went
saw Black Panther and there was a black
family in a row like right in front of
you don't say and uh they were cool they
were talking but there was a point in
the movie where the grandmother pulled a
giant container a potato salad I started
scooping it and giving it to everyone in
the family in the middle of the movie
and he's like oh I think and this was a
black guy my friend and he's like I did
not think they were black enough for
this movie and then when they did that
day like cause my grandma Carol we were
very hungry
yes great you know gotta be pissed the
Black Panther honestly blade I mean
blade was such a great movie and did not
come alone anyone should they do a blade
versus with black panther now heads will
explode
our blade is he's the only black thing
in it other than his outfit sitting yeah
yeah yeah there's tons of black oh it's
all black is that why mostly black I
respect that yeah I respect that Ivan
see I think I'm gonna go this week it's
like a wedding reception it was awesome
this is great it's great how come you
can note this the whole movies purple
everything I said on the show black
people love purple I do I'm very true
that says color of his dick yeah that's
pretty dark in the right lighting it
looks like a [ __ ] flower Oh purple
look at this guy who loves black people
about black chicks yeah I just I would
love to be with a black girl I was your
ideal I also don't have the confidence
Serena Williams you're sorry Williams
over Serena wait you you're into black
chicks who's your ideal black chick what
chick running around would you like I
mean my Rudolph are you a Haddish one
this sounds like a slave auction like
we're all running around do you want
that erase what we will roleplay in the
bedroom of course yeah exactly that's
right you like that yeah oh I'm in weird
house I'm gonna drop an N bomb on me
make me work hard I mean no offense to
anybody but like who would you like to
take out for like females at the Comedy
Store running around what black ass
would you like who would you like to
take out for it would you like to that
one that's banging Jeffrey Ross
occasionally that one who at least looks
like she is hanging out with him no
who'd you like to take off our nice
watermelon
this is behalf no no time called for and
it's rude it's rude that a way to get
two black women and again it's a third
date thing not a first date thing you
know where you live third day and I lose
out great one Mel stop yeah this is
where Chris can now make racist comments
about white people well I've done no
wrong exploded just he will
well there's no but there's no steam you
guys rule the world so it's like what
can I say that's like yeah this hurts
women do now
white women white women Hollywood that's
just Hollywood yeah but anyways Chris
would you like to say anything about
like disparaging about white people we
will say here and just take it no that's
okay I'd like to continue my career if
you Paul Yassir Lester on on Twitter he
goes really hard on white people Dez
guard because he I guess he's very
light-skinned though yeah he acts like
he was born he like he has to break
bondage every day and take it
Underground Railroad to whatever vh1
show he's writing on every [ __ ] day
it's unbelievable
I love Yasser but man that guy is
oppressed dude oh are you guys
oppressing Yasser so much here's the
deal every other like strongest militant
types or super light-skinned have you
noticed that I'm okay Malcolm X I'm okay
seems like they're all [ __ ] really
angry because they gotta overcome on say
MLK it's not like skin what the [ __ ] are
you talking hold on
how many people here say I'm ok is like
I skin that's light-skinned
yeah dude dude have you seen that guy on
the Kentucky basketball team that's
black hardcore do I don't even do
sponsorships anywhere yeah I'm ok he's
light-skinned I don't look at the black
and white photo and be like look at him
he's gone well I use the guys on the
right here now but see that's a good
contrast see all the dark brothers hold
on say Malcolm X's light-skinned Malcolm
X is super light-skinned Malcolm X was
redhead let him look that up look that
up literally a redhead you trying to say
chunky white he's a landscape
ok he's is my holy [ __ ] yeah dude I know
my black skin tone I gotta be honest
with you man they make him darker in
every picture you see looking at
pictures
the one when he had when he was Detroit
red and he's got the [ __ ] is that Yassir
Lester
it looks like yessir right it's
unbelievably totally right dude
yeah they got to over compensate for the
lack of ability
everybody should Blake Griffin out there
man Wow fun fact of the day dropping
knowledge you just blew my mind
so what black chicks do you like yeah
which ones are the cool ones who are the
good ones ones like they're badly know
which ones are the ones you want to know
I got celebrity you're like what what's
the one who gets stage time all the time
to calm me start late nice she's really
funny yes hyung he's got some cannons
honor yes he does
he shown him to me a lot of yeah she
died Tehran she's always like Oh Sam you
weren't supposed to see that I put her
in a poem I not once
whoa and then I flipped her into the
pool whoa or what wow that is not
something you want to do the plugs right
I got a shudder on my whole body when
you said that by the way the bar staff
at the Comedy Store is like a commercial
marketing wet dream is literally one of
everybody it's like a community college
it's like Chinese Asian guy yeah baby we
get along great well I'll get along
great they're like a family to like yeah
there's nobody that's I currently all
licking nipples back there certainly
right that's just Wednesday
Candace Thompson would you hit it I
would she's hot I would it's okay ah a
higher standard than you I was for some
other way I don't know are you kidding
me Jess I loved yeah I'm saying Yoko Ono
and well if I data I know the fact that
I know that no black women will listen
to this episode
as many black women that watch this or
the same amount that would actually bang
you you got no shots I have no chance in
real ones he's [ __ ] yep
I'm not black girl I've never been with
a black girl ever I know but that's your
number one thing knowing the more thing
I love black when I wouldn't mind it I I
like black I I wanted mine I would love
it actually I watch out at still I lot
of the problem I watch is with black
women with white guys I like I can't
watch that can make you a suicide the
white dick it's just like oh I'm out of
it I'm out of it but I also like
watching black guys [ __ ] white I know
that I know that I like both but I don't
like black and black and I'm not by the
white yeah dude you you like your [ __ ]
futuristic spice well have you been
watching there's a lot of like we are
seeing the interracial the like two
three generations of more acceptable
interracial especially in the sports man
I mean like you look at like all
basketball there's a lot of
light-skinned brothers out there I'm a
very higher militant are you guys
excited about the NCAA tournament I know
you're an avid avid sports I do not come
off as a sports guy by doing those for
you do like sport but you walk around in
Jersey Jersey today because I gotta go
for my pelicans when I'm not eating your
food and you're screaming at everybody
you're not washing your faces are calm
there's a couple teams who is your pick
to win it all
ah you know man I have a couple people I
think Virginia's pretty deadly and I'm
dying to see how Arizona goes that kid
that Center is pretty good man my team
against state I'd like to see her do get
deep I'd like to see Purdue get deep I
would be very surprised if Michigan
State goes pretty far Michigan stays
that big they have some big guys I think
you know that Jett Jackson junior kid is
good man I wanted and they Anna's kind
of weak bracket we have Kansas which is
whatever I think
this won't make it to the end I'd only
can't Kansas I don't like weird season
because they weren't killing it effort
although all the top teams had the
weirdest ease well if you're doing ones
and Duns a lot if you do want and Duns
you're gonna get [ __ ] lit up you know
yeah what number one in the SEC was what
all burn but just crazy you're right
right not Kentucky yeah yeah well
Kentucky if you keep going to that one
and done you're gonna get a batch of
guys who really aren't that great I mean
like and that's why Kentucky has its
might be Calipari said this might be one
of his youngest teams that it is the
youngest team I ever yeah I mean they're
tall freshmen but there's just nothing
no doubt nothing just a bunch of young
kids who just truly not play bass I can
see Michigan playing spoiler I can see
he Gonzaga playing spoiler I don't think
it's ugh Houston is somebody could do
some damage so Clah Homa can get hop it
they're also they can get calls so
Johnny I know you're not on Mike but
North Carolina's coming out this way
is it LA they're going and then LA so
that what is the date on that because
guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be how
would you get seats Sam we're gonna go
to see key that's right seat geek for
all of your ticketing needs our good
friends that seek make it so easy to to
get tickets I do it all the time you
just go you download the app I got
tickets to The Avett Brothers on CK kit
Santa Barbara Bowl thank you thank you
thank you me and my sister are going
yeah put in the code punch-drunk and
guess what that gets you 20 bucks off
your first time you get tickets here's
what's great about the app when you have
it on your phone no matter where you are
let's say you're in you know Chicago be
hanging out go to see geek it'll tell
you all the concerts that around you all
the supporting Benson around you you can
go to NCAA tournament let's see what
these are ladies and journeys is this a
tournament oh really okay what's
a little higher because I'm gonna go oh
wow Staples Center I guess is the
n-c-double-a tournament what oh really
yeah especially especially if it's some
teams as aren't big but it ranks them
from expensive to cheap and good seats
too bad seats and you can literally put
in your price points and it'll find
things it'll literally find you what you
want
I am literally use a cup puncher I've
used it a thousand times and I've never
had any problems
I've used it probably twenty times and
I've used it in three different states
oh snap yes sky stage and wherever I go
it just tells me what's going on when
I'm there guys I mean tend to rob this
book breaking news hold on hold on hold
on did you just interrupt the read what
I tell you there's whatever that you
guys were done with the ring yeah we
were done with the read what's a
breaking news and so thanks eek eeeek we
love you and you scope on trunk twenty
bucks off your first purchase downloaded
glad you did it very thankful Sam
Bradford Cardinals hours own Cardinals
will get Sam Bradford no I mean is that
their guy I think they're probably gonna
draft somebody that's what's up and then
they're gonna use him for one too I mean
that talk about a guy you know here's a
we're generator ever degenerative knee
well that's not worth we're thinking
here this guy gets paid all the time but
he just can't reach his level
athletically you know that's 31 more NFL
games than you and I have but he's a
late night what like a hundred mill corn
nuts
uh-huh it's unbelievable I'm dying to
see how this droughts can go cuz there's
a lot of great draft but yeah man so now
we see cause instead the Vikings cousins
we said that on this show the day the
NFL season ended we said that on this
show yes I uh do you think he's and I
had heard that from Andrew and I said I
don't so what we kind of had like easy
the perfect fit for that team is that a
good absolutely going to a good team oh
yeah great and he's set and he's great
fine he's fine really
yep they just now have to worry about
defense I mean the best offensive
lineman's ever has offensive line insane
three good receivers and a grid good
tight end they're gonna draft maybe one
more weapon for him and and delegate who
comes back Devon cook comes back so it
he doesn't have to throw like he did in
Washington ah who's Washington's running
back okay J Jackson exactly exactly yeah
he hasn't had a backfield ever that's
yeah yeah Alfred Morris oh yeah for 12
games with one year almost [ __ ]
killed her that one year yep sure as one
of the three years that he's been
franchise tagged he had a running back
for 14 games he's got a guy that can
take 30 carries a game now so he doesn't
have to do that [ __ ] he called him with
a bullet
yeah called it I mean he knew where he
wanted to go because that's the best
place for him to go now when Tyrod
Taylor went to Cleveland do you think
that started the Domino's like
everyone's I'll [ __ ] we gotta get our
quarterbacks quick well that was a trade
right yeah but still I mean when free
agency started which was today Oh today
yeah now I mean so everything else has
been everything's off trade tomorrow
yeah it's all been trades or handshake
trades actually because they're not
official till tomorrow so they're like
hey we're gonna make we've agreed on
this trade it'll be official in a week
so that's what we've been hearing about
now free agency is open and now you're
getting these people like you know the
rumors are true now okay he's going
there he's going to not ruin here
because they their facts that's I'm
saying they're true now right what has
been a rumor right cousins to mental
what was the deal cousins because you
remember they were talking like I don't
know him 70 bill for one year I'm like
why would you do that
go to the Jets no why would you pay yes
to read what do you get way to get
eighty four million for three years yeah
it's all guaranteed guaranteed 84
militate he's still taking a pay cut
Foley guaranteed a 4 mil and that's
still a peck on your dough would I think
he only did three because after that 3
years he's getting a huge look at that
dude he goes cur cousin hero for all
young players that will follow after him
now we need more players to batten
themselves until fully guaranteed
tricks at a norm and not the exception I
think fully guaranteed contracts will be
the [ __ ] death of the NFL it's
hurting the MBA and it's like I like
players getting paid but it's let's face
it man which sometimes when people get
paid they don't live up their contracts
and then you're stuck with these cons I
agree with you you know I don't mind
well you really hurt a small market
teams the most small market teams is who
it decimates well let's take a look at
the Knicks let's take a look at the
Lakers I mean these are teams that sign
guys the big contracts and just it
didn't pan out so now they're stuck with
these contracts I don't mind people
dating cover that nut they can cover
that nut well it doesn't matter when the
Timberwolves signed somebody to a mat
like some max outt guarantee thing it
ruins their franchise for 20 years
well what happened to actually the
Timberwolves was that David Stern
dropped a hammer on them because they
negotiated with Joe Smith a special
contract for the next year and he found
out and he just pounded them and took
away four [ __ ] first-round draft
picks that destroyed their team Johnny
what is this yeah Wow Carson Wentz is
there any way Casey I mean Matt Ryan
Case Keenum is good he played in Kansas
City with is that where he went he's in
he's with the Broncos now so he owned
that Kansas City I'm sorry Houston I'm
sorry I believe is ginam yeah yeah he
went to Denver but one of the coaches at
Denver it's used to coach with Houston
he was a Raider or RAM to nobody
one of the coaches that Denver right now
used to be a coach in Houston and they
work together yeah there's that
connection between I mean it's either a
starter or they just draft one I think
they draft one and they have a guide to
help a guy build up Case Keenum
engineering system in minutes that's a
weird new job in the NFL which is
quarterback gate keeper the Case Keenum
Xand all those people are like hey man
which used to be like who is that guy
whether it was a Niner
he was dating a Playboy Playmate Oh Jeff
Garcia and everybody was like ah she
loved Garcia of the gecko yeah
Garcia journey was basically but that
was yeah journey like a journeyman is
now like the gatekeeper like you know
what you could play 16 games for us and
we don't have to pay you - too much
money well we figure out a quarterback
situation exactly and everything else is
I mmm I was oh boy Hayes Kingdom is
apples for that just dead just wanted
goddamn superb alright who's that dude
is married a hot chick they're all men
jobs like checked it was an actress and
then he was the Eagle for a long time
and I mean you're still black a black
quarterback black quarterback black
quarterback McNabb now McNabb but
Michael babe oh no rodney peete also a
journeyman also yeah keeper yeah my
Super Bowl I mean he didn't start but he
did win a Super Bowl for what's called
uh who'd he win it with it cuz he is a
he is a radio show here all the time he
won a Super Bowl I do maybe he was on
the Pats who was he odd but he won one
he was a backup yeah I'm more interested
a little wife is now black chick was an
actress she's hottest [ __ ] Oh Holly
Robin Robinson Peete yeah boom hanging
with mr. Cooper all day Cooper well he's
a little darker she's light she did look
at the contrast yeah you can see it down
there yeah he they've been together for
a while
he pulled a Roethlisberger - of course
he ain't lettin her go he pulled a
Roethlisberger which is the day I
retired the date Roethlisberger retires
he puts on 65 pounds yeah well that dude
is just waiting to be fat yeah Byron
Leftwich same thing well Jenny look up
when he was firing left which fell off
the mat it's so it I must say something
Kris nothing you agree with that it is
it is much harder to stick around the
NFL as a black quarterback than it is a
white quarterback oh yeah he didn't win
he was yeah he was with the Panthers
yeah that's right lost had lost but he
was in the Super Bowl but lost who's
there you were there
playing would you play not in play I was
at the one in Arizona
no you're just hanging out no no that
was Seattle New England do you have do
you have a team yeah I'm for Niners fan
huge fan what is that that's it they're
gonna be good dude yeah they're Sherman
do anything yeah of course you mean I
don't know Manny you know just it's
helped made him too much yeah Sherman
yeah no way that contracts all incentive
Layden like if he doesn't show if
nothing happens he gets a ham sandwich
they call today even that might be too
much this question if he's gonna do
anything and it was and that's just a
bad injury the cut that he suffered to
come back 34 31 31 yeah once you're 30
in these pros I mean it is like you know
and like that's what I'm concerned about
my pelicans but DeMarcus Cousins with
Achilles injury at his who knows what
the well you know Bret Elton Brand was
never the same effort a lot of these
guys or never kill again you know
clipper curse you know he just wanted he
just was he actually came back for 15
games just show everybody and just ran
to [ __ ] in Philly but they loved him in
Philly because he just was a veteran you
know and he helped that team came back
last year to help them is that crazy
last year was Elm brands last year I
didn't even know he's an illegal yeah he
was in the league forever is Vince
Carter's or the year before
yeah he's he a Hall of Famer
Vince Carter yeah I think he gotta be I
think he is I think yeah he's like a
third voter you know like he did not not
first ballot right yeah yeah if he would
have retired a long time ago he could
have been first pal I mean like people
forget how like it was him an AI going
at it all the time in the East but I
think that like when people retire early
we get his numbers early do 25 27 I mean
that's like
27 24 25 I mean those are monster nom
not to mention all the highlights I mean
the vent sanity arrow was like have a
[ __ ] to watch you know look at Vince
with Toronto with some of my favorite
teams of watching basketball because I
remember the kid watching it and all the
time is seeing because I'm already
starting I'm worried Damon Stoudamire
yeah was my favorite basketball player
guys are the same hell no I've always
liked him at all his basketball car yeah
and I remember what college you play for
Arizona Arizona yup he was part of that
really great draft class - it was him
well actually was it a great draft class
or she Marcus Camby who was else in that
draft class it was like this crazy ass
draft class I was that the nutty one
where it was like [ __ ] it was like Grady
you know this guy I know that is before
that it was crazy dude craziest draft oh
there it is dude
yep yep that was it Stephon Marbury
here's a crazy thing about Stephon
Marbury he's a hall-of-famer and I know
you guys think I'm a Allen that is the
one I'm talking about cuz Kobe's in it
yeah when Nash yeah look at that
Ray Allen Walker made so much money and
lost it all then you get some and he's
just stuck on who are the keep going
down Kobe I used to love KK Jermaine own
Jermaine O'Neal was a [ __ ] killer
Walter McCartney garbage Derek Fisher
good yeah dude Roy Rogers I thought was
gonna do something dude I remember that
Travis Knight the white is Laker to ever
play the game
I don't know mark Madison and now Travis
Knight was even wider than that look
like yeah dude I mean like just oh yeah
team that's probably the greatest is
that the greatest draft no no no no no
no I
Allah bronzes and then there's uh
there's another one that's pretty [ __ ]
what is the draft class with Paul Pierce
in it the Paul Pierce draft class I
think is the greatest
which one is it wait a minute 1984
before it's pretty vicious I think
that's it no not 96 go up but look at
that I mean Jordan Berkeley and Akeem
that is a great one come on that is
ground Stockton or soar
I think this this is a great one that's
a great one and now we're starting to
see these guys start to fall out yeah
you know Patrick Ewing Xavier ax man
that's a bad Oakley Karl Malone Jojo I
mean how many reporters big-ass alien
head that's a good one I can look at
that one dude Terry Porter looking like
a milk dud they gave us with eyes that's
a lot of fun he did hop
Vince Carter a lot of Lakers stop what
well wrong with that he literally looked
like I milked up with eyes I agree I
think Sam Cassell is the same thing what
race is about that statement no raisins
thank you all right unkind like people
like you can't say anything bad about
black people or it's racist yeah I'm
down with that
be cool look at that guy looks like an
alien race is about saying that I agree
rg3 looks like for a teams dude you had
some great Steve he looks like another
mouth is gonna come out alien right
right great team terrifying that clipper
team got [ __ ] by the refs against
Steve Nash's oh my god thought you and
these Clippers ah they suck no they
don't do no we don't know no wait
[ __ ] seven better than we were before
cool seven see do my ass well you guys
are to play out where's it gonna get you
on the Lakers it'll play of all four
games out the Laker games out about four
games out go out that's the law right
there dude I mean like trouble because
they lost they lost Porter I'm not
Porter Jimmy Butler we're like halogens
Clippers could get up to the five
imagine if we got to the for some weird
way I mean we got a killer stretch of
games we could be in trouble but
imagine if we got to the forum where the
exact same exact same there's also a way
we don't even make the flash it's
possible and I'm cool with either one
dude because I could see that I can see
the Jazz moving up jazz or playing
consistent well and then the Nuggets and
who knows if Leonard plays for the Spurs
the Spurs can be right back in it I
thought was if I was the UH if I was the
there's a couple teams like Cleveland
that needs like they don't if LeBron
stays that's a big if they could they
could bake again I have a top three top
four pick that they could send to San
Antonio for Kawhi Leonard it's like why
not dude you know yeah I think Cleveland
would need a new coach I don't think but
if you're gonna keep LeBron yeah LeBron
I don't think Hugh is the coach
magically the team of LeBron Kawhi and
Kevin Love that's a good squad but he
doesn't here's the third guy all one's
dude you know all one that I think you
can get a better guy about big I think
Kevin watch you know needs that this the
the Sacramento Kings need to stop
drafting Sacramento and Phoenix need to
stop directing drafting Kentucky players
and get a veteran on a team that's why
I'm surprised they both turned down
Blake Griffin I was like dude he's a
perfect guy for your [ __ ] team you
need a [ __ ] something to build on now
poor Blake Griffin is just melting in
Detroit I mean he is bright I feel I
like he's still one of my favorite
players I feel for that guy he is in
[ __ ] freefall right now dude he wants
to be LeBron James his skill set isn't
that he's [ __ ] look at his number
he's trying to pull up LeBron James
numbers which is like 22 23 8 and 8 and
it's like we don't need you to do a nay
we need you to do 24 25 points and 10 to
12 rebounds but he doesn't like that
game anymore he doesn't like to get hit
dude and it's just he got he got injured
to an injury down low and he doesn't
want to get injured the danger before he
was drafted so he yeah he didn't play
this all rookie here he was injured
before that - yeah ginger was injured
before his
you know what he should be militant but
yeah he should get into that like
[ __ ] sorry he should be cat what
about Kaepernick light-skinned brother
exactly yeah you're getting it now
holy [ __ ] you're right Johnny Sam Blake
is wrong just Danvers I mean the
rebounds four rebounds eight three Reba
I mean like dude you need him to rebound
nobody he has no one else on that team
yeah I'm REE Drummond I would take Andre
Drummond a thousand times over
no one's a point though no one really
point and that's what Blake Griffin
needs that's why he like cp3 worked so
well together
cp3 ran the point and [ __ ] did it
he's gone sued by his ex right now and
she's like dish Oh Blake is dishing all
of his [ __ ] dirty long yeah that's
what happened he [ __ ] started hooking
up with the Kardashian that's why I like
Anthony Davis he gets Android quite a
bit but he's he's slowly evolved his
game to the horses over
she's not gonna [ __ ] go to Detroit
there's so many [ __ ] pro athletes out
her he's so oh here I can't believe any
of the Kardashians have him [ __ ] a pro
baseball player that's blows my mind
they only love basketball occasionally
bill to you they're too high-profile
baseball players don't fall out like
that no I mean basketball players very
hearty like that level of Fame why
they're like popping champagne kind of
[ __ ] hey my god we can't hear you
they [ __ ] golfers and a lot of the
time dudes they all speak Spanish look
at the murder row that they've done va
players
[ __ ] who what the [ __ ] [ __ ] under
Jewish black guy who isn't he Jewish who
Matt cab isn't he
no is he militant he's very
light-skinned oh wait a minute is
baseball news first no okay well he
should convert I know there was Jewish
baseball sites do famous yeah let's go
down the murder row of the Kardashians
can you go to the top go to go to the
top starts being not the first that's
the beginning go to top okay here we go
who have they destroyed okay oh yeah
Todd who Todd Waterman who's that
yeah that's what the beginning of the
article that's where it starts Todd
Waterman destroyed and here we owe ya
this was the first yeah kid Kris
Humphries destroyed by them then oh yeah
McCants destroyed by them Jordan
Clarkson
goodbye body destroyed by them Derrick
Ward nobody even knew what destroyed and
it seems like one is even worse than the
rest of them look at her dude she loves
black athlete dick huh who doesn't
Tristan Thompson like he stuck with her
but he's destroyed he's done
Chandler part yep destroyed finally went
white that didn't last long
he's the worst Miles Austin was out of
the league within a year of dating that
gone who's this oh the Armenian he looks
Armenia yeah or meaning that's the first
Armenian I'm Armenian crime they
committed their vaginas like the man was
Hamilton who is that I don't know
damn they were racecar driver yeah
Reggie Bush shot destroyed that Maya
camp destroyed that destroyed destroyed
lamar odom an tours as tea boats a milk
dud oh okay Hardin is surviving nobody
died really hot and he went hard like it
was bad hard to remember to year or last
year now year before Oh Jay Simpson was
a good man he was a good man a good
black man he was a good man not black
man just a good man wasn't black he was
OJ's
and a meltdown he literally said I think
he's literally the only one who hasn't
just [ __ ] crashed and burned
yep Bruce Jenner never crash and burn
well awesome parts of his body but he
think is it gone please never cut that
off yes there ever been in ma'am Majid
doing all that and then no TV [ __ ] you
guys see that
Oh Jay thing no I haven't I did but
that's from like years ago right yeah
it's from like some Wow What did he say
I did a hypothetical if he did it but he
said it into the can can you talk for
the black community yeah of course he
did Oh Jay do it yeah you're just saying
that right I'm not just saying okay
there's a reason the blood evidence was
like asking Sam if he paid all of his
bets off properly a year a year or what
a year you've owned this one bet over a
year you're saying you paid every one of
them off exactly I paid every bet off
every Bell oh you watch a two-hour horn
you watch a two-hour game barn yep no
you did it yeah I did we had to watch
close to I watched two hours of gay porn
it was actually better than what you're
talking about I had to do copulation
porn we were just like just [ __ ]
rocking you that break [ __ ] yeah
multiple guy no breaks I just searched
porn every five minutes people but
you're lying dude you're lying
let's go back please talk to me oh
please talk to us about why Oh Jay is
innocent that's a couple reasons aid the
blood evidence was [ __ ] okay
the timetable look the hypothetical the
timetable just came out from the [ __ ]
address of the murder back to his house
didn't work out there was no [ __ ]
evidence he was tried for this thing
everybody forgets that like it wasn't
just Cochran being a minister rhyming
and rapping is interesting about this
new thing is interesting I mean so wait
explain no people think that it's just
like Johnnie Cochran like doing a circle
there was a guy things that weren't but
none of the evidence was usable so it's
like the first time they they couldn't
just put a black man in prison like they
used to yeah totally
he still might be why people were used
to
doing that and they could with again he
wasn't black he was oj those words that
came from his own mouth you honestly
don't believe
oh gee killed those two I think he knows
what happened I think he knows what
happened son possible anything's
possible
no I think it was some drug [ __ ] that
she got involved with you know I mean a
bunch of those waiters from the
restaurant that golden work that had
been murdered previously what look that
up yeah look this [ __ ] up
a bunch what's a bun five six it only
takes really more than one be a bunch of
murders when it comes to murder that's a
bunch it's to Comedy Store door guys
were murdered it'd be like yeah you said
a bunch of the door guys have been
Mohammed - they're like - that's a lot
of murders yeah if you go a bunch and I
go holy [ __ ] a bunch and you go yeah -
and we're not talking about dicks you
suck we're talking about murder
yeah we're talking about very different
murders a bunch is that what is this oh
they brought to you by cat like I love
also my conspiracy theories can't be uh
can't get ads on YouTube but uh AJ talk
about hypotheticals I thought it was on
Fox okay cuz it was like a whole two
hour show on Fox the other day in creepy
fashion they've kind of wink wink
Simpson apparently is gonna say you know
if I committed the murders here's how I
would have you believe somebody purchase
Goldman's dad is a part of the
production served a long prison term for
burglary what
Goldman's dad was part of the production
Oh cuz he got all the money yeah
but it's like he talks about like he
wants justice you want to OJ behind bars
where the bloody clothes somebody had to
get rid of the bloody clothes typed in
2006 the ex football star was asked to
speculate about what might have happened
in 1994 when his ex-wife Nicole Brown
and her friend Ron Goldman were murdered
I want me to do this it was very
difficult for me because it's
hypothetical I know and I accept the
fact that people are gonna feel whatever
were they gonna fit Simpson has always
proclaimed his innocence if it doesn't
fit you must acquit and during his
criminal trial was found not guilty but
he later recorded the interview and
detailed what he called a hypothetical
account of the crime why would you do
that if you're him going to his
ex-wife's house with the so called
friend named Charlie came by and
mentioned something about what was going
on at her house I don't know why you'd
been buying a Cole's house but it told
me you wouldn't believe what's going on
over there after a huge public outcry
the interview never aired and the book
was shelved with the rights later given
to the Goldman family who released it
under the title if I did it confessions
of the killer
since then Simpson served nine years
behind bars for a botched armed robbery
I've basically had spent a conflict free
life relation actually had the opposite
of that said the opposite of a conflict
free life a knife but I believe he took
it Charlie took the knife you go through
the back gate yes and while I was there
the guy shows up and the mood I was in I
started having words with him Nicole did
come out and we started having words as
things got heated I just remember the
call fell and hurt herself
and this guy kind of got into a karate
thing
it's our ninja mm I grabbed the knife I
do remember that portion taking the
knife from Charlie better be honest
after that I remember except I'm
standing there and it's all kind of
stuff around and so you still don't
think he did it kind of stuff yeah yeah
hypothetical what I mean it's weird it's
super weird I'm not gonna give you
normalcy on that generation but it's
[ __ ] yourself in that situation to
even do this why would he do most of the
things he's done in his life why
wouldn't you're a [ __ ] like public
enemy number one
do you are the guy for your [ __ ]
merchandise like Chris Burns the guy who
doesn't get it that's who all Jay is
clearly Wow can you argue that like he's
has a normal outlook on life I mean for
a very long time he seemed like he did I
mean he's Charlie [ __ ] Charlie yeah
oh yeah then Charlie hands me a knife
like Charlie nightclub that like he is
Charlie yeah [ __ ] totally true
I'm not even sounding like a made-up
story oh dude goes into a karate thing
talking about I think you're holding on
to it I think you just can't come to
grips with it you think there is there
let me ask you if every is every black
man I'll pull over by cop is it because
of racism
no absolutely not okay absolutely not we
had break just most of them just do
stupid [ __ ] those of its there's
accidental know without a doubt don't
know there's obviously institutional
racism the truth is that is that black
people don't carry drugs as much as
white people just some people get stuck
with it a little more and that's the
truth I mean I've been arrested went to
jail I've been pulled over 18 times on
traffic violations some of you might
think it's my driving I think it's me
yeah 18 were texting and driving I want
to say never speeding never running
through life all 18 texting and driving
right let's give some bad skee-ball we
have playing games today right is that
today
how many playing games are there for
what is this - today what are you doing
this is the brackets or determinant and
the percentages of certain teams I have
to win depending on what you click on
but how does UCLA getting to the
tournament and use USC does what UCLA is
one of the playing games right how's you
dude USC and Oklahoma State got [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well USC never beat a top 25 team or
something like that second they were the
second seed in the pac-10 tournament the
second seat yep there's a lot I guess
Oklahoma State got [ __ ] dude they beat
Kansas twice they be Florida State they
beat like Oklahoma I mean like dude they
got [ __ ] man Oklahoma State got [ __ ]
USC Trojans [ __ ] you know our IP RPI
34 dude I mean 34 that's unbelievable
where's Oklahoma State Notre Dame - yeah
but look who they played st. Mary's
versus who I mean the pac-12 but still
how do you end the season at 25 and then
not make a 64 tops you know yeah uh even
without winning your you know yeah buddy
Oklahoma State RPI is high place worse
isn't and they were eight and ten in the
big 12 oh they were swept by okay under
yeah I guess they lost those what they
wanted West Virginia they want one at
Florida State they won in Oklahoma they
wanted Kansas you know it's better than
you see us thirty said look at that dude
they were better than UCLA
now the best victories came over there
went yeah their biggest way yeah and
they lost I'm gonna Princeton
well Princeton runs that that white boy
offense at home yeah and they play
Barney they pay off and you know it's
politics you see lays a bigger program
and that is exactly and I love UCLA I
love going to the I look I love the
tournament and I think a lot of people
like I don't know you went to UNLV so
obviously I get to you like them
Ball State never makes tournament you
like all la team you like didn't go to
come with a bunch of light-skinned black
oh is that all black school it is we had
three Wow was there white do you think a
white chick could come and survive in
all black cut races to come on we gonna
survive like just get her ass beat by
black chicks constantly who know I don't
white black women hate white girls they
hate them they don't hate them they hate
them when they date black dudes which is
all that most of but again most of white
chick went to Morehouse yeah that's
about that way they film that one Cosby
Show thing no that was real right no
there's no Hillman college there's none
no you sure you okay guys let's get our
pinions on who he thinks in a way at all
I mean I'll tell you who I'm pulling for
I would love to see Perdue in the Final
Four
and do some damage a good team they got
that big guy they got a big dude
I mean [ __ ] someone oh it was good
I'm gonna go uh turn out I'm gonna go uh
final for Purdue all right no champ ship
game Purdue five percent chance of
winning yeah Purdue Xavier / dude Savior
that is the most unfuckable final
horrible that's right down
that's a make the [ __ ] dry final right
there that is a I like Virginia but the
the thing that sucks is that Arizona is
in there is in their bracket right
where's there those are [ __ ] who has the
highest percentage chance of winning
Johnny Virginia I do like 18:4 vision I
do like Virginia
they're just ballers dude that nobody
talks about the record 26 and to an ACC
that's [ __ ] amazing that's amazing to
me okay so we would like to plug a
couple things real quick we are going to
have our traditional punch-drunk
brackets would do that to be done by
today yeah you got to get them done by
today or you know whatever you can games
don't start till Thursday so you miss
out on the playing games but go to you
know our Facebook page Pancho exports
calm which will be out in two weeks our
Twitter and everything else and get
involved we'll figure out who wins what
but we'll send you something if you win
I know we're gonna get in the UFC soon
but I just want to say that punch-drunk
is going to have its first official live
UFC viewing party okay April 27th I mean
April 7th
it is UFC 2 223 Ferguson vs. khabib and
it will be live at Sycamore tavern we're
gonna put this out
and come down viewing party it's free to
get in great food great drinks and all
the punch-drunk fans we're all gonna
watch it together there is no charge at
this bar so come down and joy even if we
got a couple people we're all gonna go
down there and watch UFC 223 so put it
in your in your calendar to come and
hang out are you gonna have somebody pay
off a bed at that line there's two
there's two belts on the line right on
that fight right yeah there is yeah
there's a rose versus Johanna Joe Jenn
chick good fights on this thing too I'm
rooting for khabib Ferguson I love I'm
mourning I am too but I love Kabir I
think Abby will win but I love Ferguson
I love Ferguson he's crazy he's got like
a [ __ ] drug lord mentality the way he
[ __ ] talks like he could easily been
in Scarface and been like [ __ ] you
wanted to take a mile you'll [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and I [ __ ] love it now
khabib is just a monster dude I mean the
guy is a monster I mean he's a monster
dude that guy could easily this is for
the 170 no 155 he could easily do 170
easily you ever see him standing next to
like a Daniel Cormier he's a big guy and
look he's got that I will crush you look
in his face like yeah very Ivan Drago
Ivan Drago a lot of ladies on this I
mean dude
then you got this [ __ ] rose fight I
love her I love I love it look at it one
of them so interesting there's some hot
UFC fighters how about that guy
everybody's in gate ugly that [ __ ]
will female Tony Hinchliffe get it done
no Willy get it done no I think that
last fight Rose girls are Johanna was
didn't take the fight as serious as she
does other fight the scene so you really
holding on to that I are you love I saw
Rose lose
Cleveland yeah and but she was great in
the you have seen Cleveland and but I I
think I want your heart of the wind
because I want a third one well I love
to see it here's the thing about Johanna
the two of them are great I like her as
a fighter to she's exciting to watch but
she's a bully and sometimes they rely
really hard I'm being a bully do you
know what I'm saying like it's almost
the mystique of that fight is more as
the mystique of them as being invincible
is almost as important to their fight as
their skills you know we see that women
like Mike Tyson and [ __ ] like that
Ronda before John right and when
somebody doesn't give a [ __ ] like that's
weird it's like dude you get to this
level everybody can take a punch
everybody [ __ ] is a got a scale it's
just so such an interesting way of opera
it just so she may have been exposed if
you know if you're not the boogey woman
I hate when she says that I'm the boogey
woman you're the baby man just call it
the boogey man you're the boogey man
nobody knows what the bully Mans gender
is we just call it the boogey man we
don't know if he's got dick he's a
light-skinned black guy crying crying
about alright not no mark that Malcolm X
was light-skinned black and white nice
UMI's dark-skinned Wow Wow
so that's gonna be it guys come on down
so who back to this you think who wins
attorney I uh want a either wad Arizona
or or Virginia they're both and you have
a dog in a fight I don't have any guy
you want UCLA to get in and run the
tables I mean they won't new you know
it's not you know I I could see Virginia
and Michigan State like Josh just a lot
of grown men on Michigan State State is
like one of those teams like when I was
in like junior high
a kid there was this a Kappa was his
[ __ ] name and it was these two
brothers OJ Simpson no no but it's black
dude he had a [ __ ] pull-on moustache
he was like 16 but he was in eighth
grade he drove off those Ivy for
Musgrove to eighth grade Jesus like
we're all like 13 and this [ __ ]
was driving the school at Michigan State
Michigan State so much Kate Dale three
different times by the way by the way
Michigan State has literally been
accused of everything this year yeah
outside was in the murder me outside of
murder and it's still playing at the
team together the spine and bring them
together
yeah when Kobe was released and we're
molesters and rapists and all this stuff
but let's come together over bass it is
all still the coach at Michigan State
yeah okay I thought so well I'm going
with little weird same I just can't
remember if you I thought like
somebody's I thought he may have left
philosophy yeah I'm going Michigan State
or Villanova hey don't we know how the
FBI story just disappeared when it
involves Duke and all these other
stories like when you're going off on
Louisville everyone's fine when you
start going after these Blue Bloods like
[ __ ] Duke people get freaked out and
they shut everything up it's
unbelievable guys but with this
tournament coming UFC fights a
basketball getting in full gear go to
bat des I bet the acai for all your
betting needs and listen man we get help
constantly for new bedding services to
promote this this podcast yeah but we
stay with our trying true are the first
people to ever advertise with us we stay
with them
Bethy aside for all your bet needs go to
Bethea sicom use the promo code punched
25 you get 25 bucks right 25 bucks and
then whatever you put in let's say you
use some of those big that big Bitcoin
money so you put a thousand bitcoins in
yes they get 2,000 bitcoins so you can
bet with whatever you want
put the money in make it happen and take
those bets we I do you when I can I do
UFC
parlays and then we'll do some betting's
on these games this is this tournament
right now
a great time to bet go in there and fill
out a bracket fill out a bracket tote
the 25 bucks on filling out a bracket
and just see how you do roll the dice
they have bets for everything bet the
si.com or dot-eu
if you're across the pond if you're
nasty ah and use a code punch 25 and
they will take care of you I yeah so
that's it man I love it
I [ __ ] love it we're blessed to have
sponsors man MBA coming down are the
heat I mean excuse me are the rockets
and legit threat to the Golden State
Warriors no yes absolutely it depends if
curry comes back healthy all depending
on curry
I would absolutely I just think it's I
mean it's championship syndrome regular
season is whatever once it's time to go
it's time to fight also I do not trust
cp3 in a playoff game about harden
he's not necessarily a guy who's know
more than others but cp3 played in the
playoffs with the Hornets in New Orleans
and never couldn't gather with clippers
as much as I love my Clippers this is
the best team he's ever gotten he's got
shooters everywhere he never had that he
never had that and it is funny that cp3
is on the same team as Eric Gordon yeah
that is for you know they together and
that was that huge trade yeah between
the pallet where horse came in I would
love to have him on the show where are
you buddy no idea out there fishing do
you know he made a lot of his money on
he owned a company that does all
lighting for concerts really that's
where he made a lot of [ __ ] that's
where he invests his money and guys if
you want call in what's the number here
guys 3 2 3 2 a 2 7 4 2 4 if you guys
want in calling now talk to Josh talk to
black people
any black questions you got I never ask
a black yeah you got ask a black here
today hey hey he thinks oj is different
change his mind change his mind
teddy bridgewater close to
deal with the Jets right now oh nice hi
you're on with black people
how's it going boys garnet hi garnet oh
you're here calling in I guess you want
to talk to us about Toronto's chances we
can talk about that or Josh's on he's
probably uh excited about Brock Lesnar
leaving WWE to go to the UFC again oh
he's doing that again yeah it's looking
like it he's like trolling WWE fans by
like taking pictures with Dana White and
shirtless I would really love if they
did it all drugged just all drugged to
the division you have to be on drugs at
the UFC offense and what do you want to
see Brock Lesnar fight and I want to see
him get beat up again
ah I mean like I just don't want to do
one fight and go though I just like he
has to do a couple fights I I think it's
I think it's that guy's humongous I
would like to see him versus another
giant do you like to see him versus
t-pain
do you think that is a big money I think
the problem with him is that when he
gets hit he can't take it I mean like a
legit hit by a legit guy
another thing with Steve a Steve a can
take a hit stars good dude it was
something that Steve a just beat can
turn how about Brock versus Jon Jones
and you can do the drugs do the drill I
want to see both you guys coming in
white hard nipples from [ __ ] well
they look like eight balls that Jon
Jones wants to do after the fight well
if that's a belt
well the belt or can do they pull the
money the doing Lesnar versus Jon Jones
Jon Jones if he ever fights again we'll
always be in the UFC is it and
unfortunately yeah I mean he's this
twisted soul I just he's a twisted soul
dude he cannot get out of his own
[ __ ] way that's the problem with
[ __ ] Jon Jones I mean dude so many
years lost that guy was should be
[ __ ] a heavyweight champion by now
that guy needs to talk to like whoever
minds Johnny Manziel got with and got
his kind of guy man sails life together
I think that's what Jon Jones needs is
to get that [ __ ] didn't last
no but I'm thinking right now
sober he's not drinking anything he's
he's slowly trying to get it back into
shape he's not playing he's playing in
the CFL he's assigned with a CFL team
he's trying to get back to into football
I think I was at the party where Menzel
found out he was dropped from his team
and management Sammy Watkins to the
Chiefs oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that hurts the
Rams a little bit they'll get somebody
to thank you so uh but I got Johnny to
ask you guys if you were around April 9
yeah versus clippers I got pretty good
tickets for you guys so all right if I'm
here do now go if I'm here I'll go it's
a Monday night I'm not able to go how if
I'm here I'll go of course I will do it
that's why I'm coming down
13 years sober that week coming down
congratulations dude super happy for you
appreciate it super happy for you yes
how can you guys make fun the way I talk
and you hear that guy talking you're
like oh that's normal that's called
Canaan that's great okay yeah but that's
still not normal English or Canada is
certainly no but candidates like like
people of North America know anyway that
was the worst then a white oh yeah so
black people are the pie already talked
about Drake he's Canadian
yeah you're just crazy Nate Ian's can
say ours and he's white great sweater to
me where do you think oh let's see you
this is hello you're on with punch-drunk
black people look a long time there's no
second time called it what the heck guys
what's up how are you cracker
I'm good scarlet talked to see if you
guys know about your brackets yet no we
haven't
I'm gonna do it today I'm gonna do as
soon as I get home I'm gonna fill it out
I I have Virginia winning it
you know I could be wrong which I
probably am which I'm probably did
killing it right now what's up
no no that's another weird yeah Gabe
killing it is Gabe who do you got
winning hey everybody quit writing these
bad yelp reviews come eat my ribbon ate
my chicken right now shame I appreciate
that uh just trying to get right with
Christ homeboy there you go okay women
what are we a jukebox what do we [ __ ]
what are you calling al what are we a
wedding band hey play [ __ ] GSP about to
call in yeah I think we live it unknown
phone number let's you it is Oh you hung
up on him huh it is [ __ ] rude it is
[ __ ] rude I'm super excited are you
guys you have a baseball team
are you baseball guy and all the
baseball guy at all I never had a bit
because New Orleans never have a
baseball team I never got into baseball
oh hello you're on with punch-drunk its
garnet again hey who's this was that it
wasn't was it
that's a just random good hair yeah so I
like oh I like it man I like the
carousel of may be so [ __ ] rude dude
so I do have a question for the two of
you or the three of you since y'all know
football since the Browns got Tyrod
Taylor yes do you think big draft
quarterback yes deal first pic now first
I perfect Barkley you cannot pass I
think they picked Barkley first you know
for they go with either Josh Ellen or
Sam I'm everybody loves that kid from
you you see how it is the best quarter
in distress I think so hi you're on with
punch-drunk yo first time long time [ __ ]
boy 69 here oh boy 69 thank you for
coming in how are ya I'm surprised that
I was already taken to minorities oh
Jesus Christ within wear black friendly
[ __ ] podcast unless you're a high
element militant yeah indeed no I'm just
talking about oh [ __ ]
That's not me so I'm fine with that I
got it I got black people questions oh
yeah hey dude don't get racist I'm dead
serious no and mom so nothing
he's our friend be respectful go [ __ ]
this black chick nice the coconut oil I
don't understand a [ __ ] they're in my
room smells like coconut oil for four
months yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] oh no you
gotta burn it with fire son you gotta
get some candles dude you gotta get or
you got to counteract that [ __ ] with
like the cocoa butter yeah I'm saying
you've used the cold more cocoa butter
no he's Tamil coconut oil yeah yeah yeah
you know how you get coconut oil out of
your bed red wine I need to get red wine
out of your bed with peanut butter yeah
yeah yeah no that's you know I know
exactly what you're talking about cause
see we got the the dryness and
moisturizing issues with us so we get in
there and the coconut oil knocks that
[ __ ] out but it does last okay you don't
get ashy balls Wow
dude ask a black it's coming and
powerful I'm a better cocoa butter as a
wife I love cocoa butter was a bit of my
favorite stripper yeah so was what was
the black chick you know what she's
super light-skinned or was she deep
space black militant wakandan or
militant she's very active sure she was
in the middle she's more of Martin
Luther King yeah
you know who is hot dog her sister
shampoo
at her all right thanks for calling dude
who's next this guy you're calling back
in what's up hey
yeah it's garnet again I want to know if
you hang up on that together Oh could
you guys things gonna make it to the NBA
Finals oh crap the Raptors gonna hold my
Toronto's gonna win the easy I don't
know I I would take Boston over Toronto
just because who is the guy that shoots
the [ __ ] shot when time is ticking
down and pressures high and don't
Toronto Houston Toronto Houston that's
your final yeah
Toronto Houston I say Toronto Golden
State I say Boston Golden State we got
another call what's caller what is this
a [ __ ] calling Boocock be cool they
were tired I know hey everybody you're
on with Park Hey
who is this who are you hey buddy how
are you he sounded like you're from West
Hollywood where are you
claremont claremont nice and tripoli and
Ari shiver on boner pills and mushrooms
of the next wrestling I'm into it I'm
into it what have you guys WWF wrestling
match yeah penetration
yeah sure this is a John Ron some gay
porn yeah we can feel two birds with one
stone that way uh I'm always down
fighting Ari Ari just one that would be
our second punch-drunk baby already
doesn't like to fight hardy doesn't like
to fight
he doesn't wanna fight he likes to talk
[ __ ] who else do we got on here
hello okay okay
hang up on the one guy there we go next
we lost most everybody give Johnny a
little power it goes not he's just
hanging up on everybody now this is why
I think Toronto King when it all is at
all this is why I think because this
Toronto has this a lot of the same guys
from previous years but they're playing
there's no one guy dominating every
[ __ ] game the rules and who makes a
job when it's [ __ ] yeah when it's on
the line is that Kyrie Irving the Steph
Curry together
I ran the [ __ ] Chamberlain with the
other guy who's your fellow who's your
finals I'm gonna go Boston versus go
light I want to say he I really want
Houston because I'm still cp3 fan but I
mean let's see how jury toe ankles comes
back that guy's got you know what dude
the wires have gotten really lucky that
Dorito ankles wasn't [ __ ] cracking
because just think about that they got a
sweet deal with him because his ankles
wouldn't be right so he got a little
less deal and it was a different
collective bargaining so that he was
making 10 mil when he should have been
making like 15 and 20 and so they were
able to sign all these other guys but
now after about four or five years after
this nice [ __ ] run they've been on
[ __ ] dude yeah his ankles aren't like
now he hurts the same ankle three time
and they're saying Golden State I wanna
go see PE I wanna go Houston versus
Boston but I was down Houston needs to
get the number one because if I wanted
all Bulls versus clippers but I'm not
but if Houston's number two and they
have to play Portland if the top four
move on and Portland three and Houston -
that's [ __ ] hard watch it's a good
team - dude they've come together it's
great that's what I think Portland can
beat Golden State and Houston if it's a
two three was your photos I mean they
hey I don't see it being Portland here's
what we always talk about home state to
run a Golden State I'm gonna go bomb I
go Boston vs. Houston because I'm gonna
go out on the line okay yes sir I want
to do this but I can't now you're on
yeah good the reason Portland is because
they feel they hit everything they got
the three level all-stars which is
obviously
Diller Damian Lillard CJ McCollum and
that that in that Center that they have
is [ __ ] good then they have a bunch
of shooters on the outside that can
score
or enter a lot a lot alight no because
Portland can hit better threes than me
then I think about a three by one shoot
nobody think to round plays bettin way
better team balled in Portland Lakers
versus Shaq and Kobe later 49ers yeah
that'd be great
it'd be great that's the sexy finals no
no he's a big Golden State fan I'm not a
fan at all
him and every fat asian in LA mocking I
warned Sara Chris Mullin Sox one time
and he was like oh you old State Fair oh
you were a golden safe and ooh when they
were oh you are rooting for them because
we're from California and that's why why
are you like Lipper's I used to like the
Clippers until I met you [ __ ] and then
it became a whole different thing
do you have to [ __ ] on your win
championship list [ __ ] loser
you guys think Philly can do anything in
the playoffs oh I like hi this is
Toronto gold state okay how you're on
with uh black people here we are hello I
saw that I saw that too it's weird right
I feel I feel for him dude it's I don't
I feel for my I know why you don't and I
respect that
I never a light he was never cool to me
so I feel for him dead I'm I know that's
that much time into something and own
none of it and just it's gone and may he
deserved that I'm not saying he doesn't
but I just feel for him dude I do I
played a lot of devil's advocate for
Tommy I get it he called me the good one
one time one of the good ones dude I'm
not saying everything about Tommy
he called you one of the good ones many
does that mean you dark slack yeah I was
I was counting money and I know he was
there and he was people know Chris used
to be the manager of the Comedy Store
absolutely yeah yeah one night after
hours I was counting up you know all the
money yeah
throw in your pocket I just heard you
know you're one of the good ones Chris
that's why we like you here and I turn
around and it was Tommy and it was just
like he liked watching me to make sure
I'm not stealing and that I don't but
whatever we do because also who was in
charge at the time who would you even
[ __ ] tell if the store was a circus
at the time yeah it's like there's no
one yeah you're the CEO in charge I'm in
charge you're in the manager when it got
when it was crazy yeah exactly
now it's like it's cool but it's
corporate it's so it's so serious now
and it's just like it's just weird it's
very weird and it is what I mean like
they gotta have a busy or else they're
gonna knock it the [ __ ] down
yeah they're gonna knock it down and
they're gonna turn into some discotheque
or some [ __ ] building you know oh you
guys hear Jay Davis now the Booker at
the Laugh Factory you hear that yeah
it's happening that's all right then
yeah it's guys good for me yeah I mean
like dude The Laugh Factory should be
getting people not everybody can get up
the store now that's cool a lot of
factory line ups Yello how's it going
welcome to ask a black well hey hey hey
how's it going man yeah really like
bored okay does everyone go for a run
right before they call that was money
money for Johnny on that that wasn't
going he clearly said he likes boys he
wasn't too hard
he was working too hard he's gotta come
back out of seven at 10:00 it's rude
that's him here we go
no it's not him hey you're on with your
own punch-drunk you there special same
we call ask Oh black black here oh
that's right
well because he actually got he had to
pay out after the divorce did black okay
yeah black for sure and you know dude
that he was doing tons of bikes and
hookers and they were just like come on
back dude you could do that you also
yeah you have to see who we embrace
after the fall yeah
like if we embraced oj after the fall so
he was black again Tiger Woods ever any
like any like us you know like um Black
Entertainment Awards does he show up to
any of those things
no but he is like because Nike went back
to him and gave him another contract oh
yeah I believe I believe he's back with
Nike because he was wearing Nike shirt
during the tournament this past weekend
yeah it's all in the daddy also of true
to - all right dude great question black
black away oh no they're just white by
default oh that's just so rude dude
they're black Tour trailblazers no no
try to make money take it a little
trailblaze yeah yeah we don't do that we
you just black we don't do first things
yeah well let me tell you black people
that trailblaze are in Portland yeah you
know dude can I just talk to you how
they always say Oh nobody's ever died on
weed
yeah rappers all the time they love to
smoke weed and [ __ ] get shot Oh
Charlotte that's not because of the weed
but they're always hi they're the only
ones shooting guns when they're [ __ ]
high I mean how many red what he's doing
Johnny what are you doing you're just
getting so little power he's going nuts
on our collars thanks dude thanks for
calling in man thank you
Wow ask your black is really powerful
we got it we might bring you on more to
do more ask applause you really should
have done this in February you're just
gonna say how do you feel about Tiger
was winning second in the tournament
this weekend III don't give a [ __ ]
everyone's like oh it's so good to see
Tiger back he's not a nice person how he
treats people like [ __ ]
he always has and he always will Tiger
Woods is a Lance Armstrong a golfer so
he definitely changes swing a hundred
percent and now he's back to seven one
four we got a seven one four what is up
hey hey bro hey bro hey bro John Smith
problem bro I know you must talk to Matt
[ __ ] too
I didn't say anything I didn't say I
just said you're not a ronin that's it
yeah I got probably that's wake up it
doesn't take much talk to me I disagree
dude yeah dude listen dude Oh John Smith
I'll find you not on block as long as
you I tell people don't come on and
don't talk [ __ ] I get I just don't need
it it's just unnecessary we're good
friends I met you at the Comedy Store I
thought where everything was good and
then I went to go check your tweets but
I'm blocked well I do too awesome Jew
propaganda okay I've been made the bad
guy on this [ __ ] show no matter how
hard I work I'm the bad guy
or he'll you know and it's just like I
[ __ ] just hire here like no I don't
wanna race guys because I don't want to
be the bad guy but you're good at it
[Laughter]
everything that you like is the bad guy
every second thing you like is the bad
guy knows you can't do rape jokes I go
that's a rape adjacent joke that's what
I'm doing it's not really a rape joke
[ __ ] go nuts I heard it went on for
like 15 minutes that's fine
Hey Dude she kept getting smacked down
you know all right John Smith I'll try
to find what is your Twitter handle Oh
fine John Smith bro he has the John
Smith John Smith bro I'll just meet bro
yeah I've been impressive and all it's
about my question oh yeah I love all
exactly left I'm the guy yeah of course
all right what do you think of this boy
Nelson Crowe cop sight
are they really fighting a Z in Bellator
is that a real fight right now it's old
guys fight anybody is gonna have ALS
it's Roy Nelson oh yeah do the - do any
of you care anymore about triple G
Canelo since the canal yes I do write
stuff do you still care about I care
about it yeah I think they should still
fight and Canelo is turning out to be a
major scumbag I mean you just turned out
to be a scumbag like I'm not happy
with that [ __ ] decision you should be
cuz you lost that fight to hug and the
fact that you got a [ __ ] ah by the
way I won 40 bucks on that draw I view
that fight that's more of a job then
well you don't know boxing who's next
ask your black I'm like they're drunk
Sports hello four four zero hello I you
hear us by the way that's the equivalent
of grabbing your purse when you're
standing around some any large
collection of blacks I even get nervous
why is that you know what I just don't
know what's about to Cedric the
Entertainer has the funniest joke I
think it's him about like when there's a
circle of black people standing around
in the circle talking and one of them
just randomly takes off running the rest
of the question Josh got up right now
and scurried off you wouldn't see me for
two days that's what happened to me
because I'm the shooting at the Comedy
Store when there was that shooting huh
yeah I left the roast battle that was
during the roast battle early because I
was obvious who won and there's about to
be like aa bunch of you about to leave
so I left early and I'm coming around
the corner by the Bell room sign and
when I did a bunch of people just
running at me dude I was out you gotta
be one yeah I'm like it might be an
elephant out there some reason these can
we just say that that that night is a
big reason why Tiffany Haddish has
exploded
she saved so many lives by getting drunk
and talking forever that the [ __ ]
Rose battle went over 40 minutes and
thus all those people in that place is
karma yeah she saved the life I
literally pulled over that night to go
to the store and just said you know what
I'm tired and then pulled off and went
home
yeah I would have been right hi you're
you're on with punch-drunk our new fun
segment ask a black black here hey
what's up guys hey how are you I've no
idea who's in the studio I haven't been
listening who's there okay Martin and
Christopher Columbus and the kardashian
Anna come right
comrade Regis built-in okay alright hey
guys every one of you who's ever there
everybody Christopher Columbus everybody
come up to Cleveland and that's it a bar
I love the show and ask me what you
think who you think is going to be the
biggest upside in the tournament this
year
oh there's gonna be some big as I've
said Davidson over Kentucky Wow
I think Davidson's a great [ __ ] team
they're a great three-point point
shooting team and I just I want to see
the curry here's the thing about
Kentucky though [ __ ] when you got all
these ones and Duns they've now been
playing together a little more and now
it becomes more of a team than a
collection of [ __ ] go right to the
league they could do some damage they
have shooters they have athletes they
have a really light skinned black and a
very dark they have that one guy that
looks like he's straight from Africa
black out now that went too far pull the
Kentucky by that I'm a from the back he
defended what do you buy nervous he eats
his hand that's how nervous here no no
that's a kid from Kentucky who everybody
wants to draft if there's a guy on
Kentucky with dreads and he's like soup
like there's Davis black that's me yeah
that guy miles de abril Miles Davis is
like literally like if the guy is black
is black that kid can play that was good
he's a good kid by the way that kid
looks really good look is that the same
kid oh my god he speaks so well that
he's a good player I was surprised last
door my you can say what the opinions of
Josh Martin is that of the guy who got
cheers on his face and is and only his
contract does not condone that kind of
talk he threw black but I think he's a
good player bacchus thing I've ever seen
he's black packets [ __ ] can you could
say what you want about Africans I don't
care oh they're a fight you don't you're
not everyone stop
Josh Martin's right
[Laughter]
look at that back to the right is like
an 18 The Lancet guy is shocked by it
you shouldn't vote definitely Ari's
opinion and it's probably we should re
since he's not here you should all have
to go see Black Panther together after
that I'm driving guys great podcast
drive yeah I can ah
final thoughts any final file that went
fast final thoughts I am that racist
okay bring me your black your pot plug
your pod uh yeah listen to the store
horsemen every week we updated we talked
about Pro Wrestling it's funny it's me
program at Edgar it's Tony Hinchcliffe
Casas Hinchcliffe have now two or three
for less than you and my final thought
is oj didn't do okay t ba guys go to our
patreon and subscribe to that please and
as well go to all comedy t-shirts come
and pick up your punch-drunk shirts and
your sam shirts and your t-shirts and
your our t-shirts and there's gonna be
some 92.7 the pod merch coming out there
for town and go to our fantasy baseball
signup for that if any of you guys are
ready for that that drafts coming soon
so sign up for punch-drunk fantasy
baseball and get involved in our
brackets [ __ ] suck it ah i want to say
thank you guys it's been a great show
you guys both killed it again
March 25th is my taping of my one-hour
special here's what I might do might
break it into two half hours and call
the first one Armageddon and the second
one zero Fox
I don't know I'm still [ __ ]
but come there's a nine 7:30 and 9:30
they're both filling up hit me up Sam
Tripoli live at gmail come and hang out
thank you to all of our sponsors thank
you to guys and the ones and twos over
there great show and we'll see you guys
next week take care everybody